what is happening there reject nation we
are back with the most 100 positively
received star wars show to have ever
existed ob1 episode 4 again joined by
our star wars expert ace ace of spades
ace tell me are you excited to see
quinlan voss qui-gon jinn assange
ventress mace windway he's back
rendar the ghost of sith lord count duke
all right guys well you know what to do
use the force to leave a like yep it
requires a lot of work do that chris
pratt jurassic world hand also subscribe
and click the notification bell to get
notified when our next reaction is up
here on the channel full length watch
longer sync up with the time code
available for super sexy rejects over at
our patreon page thank you to the boys
of prepper for helping us edit this down
and also check out ace's youtube channel
uh final cut pro or
great tutorials secret tutorial program
you're doing a good job there man i
definitely watch it every day all right
let's get to it
[Music]
one of them should just be george
lucas's face those were a couple new
droids in there spark
live long and jedi
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
nice parallel
i hear the vader voice
oh my god
this is a terrible sensory deprivation
take experience
[Music]
your burns your body they just need time
we're on your beam you're safe now
where's leia
oh
meanwhile it's kind of like when finn
was like where's rey in the last jedi
the empire doesn't take kindly to jedi
sympathizers he will come for me oh
obi-wan is dead
nobody's coming for you
hmm
roken
you shouldn't be here oh there he is is
that o'shea yeah i need your help to get
her back general
i'm sorry but that's not my problem you
have no idea what the empire is capable
of look if you want my help
you got it
huh
super easy
change his changes really fast
we need to find a way inside we're not
soldiers those feeders are for hauling
sewage she's 10 years old i won't leave
her there i'll go on my own you can
barely stand you're not getting in there
i'll go with him well i have officer
clearance i can get you inside
dead
you think people in star wars take space
travel for granted
god light speed is taking so long
oh look he's he's forcing it
[Laughter]
you can't force the force man past is a
hard thing to forget and you just need
time that's all some things can't be
forgotten
you care about leia
then you're gonna have to try
we're almost there
you're gonna have to
get in shape real quick man workout
montage yes seriously
force workout
safe house
like the one you were in has been found
in two systems
i need to find out where they are leia
and i think
you know
how did he die
he burned to death on mapusa
bring me his body if you tell me where
the path is
you can go home to your family
i don't know anything about a path
well let's think a little bit harder
shall we it's that attitude that gets
alderaan blowing up leia
[Music]
it's a beautiful ass shot
just gonna walk right through the front
door
identification
no admittance without clearance i have
office class c now please
that's a huge cameo
this isn't your sector i can't let you
through and i'm your commanding officer
and you will address me sir yes sir of
course but i'm here with classified
intelligence do you know what classified
means
yes sir of course
you're not donald gleason
hux's dad
this is old school
very old school phantom menace
you should be right ahead of you this is
so cool
sounds like a video game level they
watched jedi fall in order and
let's do that
what did he do just threw him in the
water i'm in
dang bro and i didn't get that guy's
disguise yeah
should have
oh
she's gonna resist contest
you've practiced our clemency area the
braver you've seen
the more afraid you are i learned that
at a very young age as well
don't
don't you do it
look at this
it's just hundreds of snokes
looks like they're everywhere
jesus
this isn't your station
come with me
damn
this is the vip lounge
we need more people with your initiative
wowie
they couldn't see everyone sneak up
there but they could hear that
over there let's go
well done diversion
we're all on the same side here these
people
they'll leave you too
to die
i'll tell you where they are i just
don't want anyone to get hurt i give you
my word
excellent i'll have to tell my father
first it's okay right you said we're all
on the same side
nice try princess
i'll never tell you where they are it's
time to make those tears real
inquisiting is hard where are you
i think i just found the secure sector i
feel like there's a twist coming with
riva let go oh let go
[Applause]
is that quinlan yeah place isn't a
fortress
not that one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i need a distraction
fine what's happened just do it now
was that the young lane at the beginning
of the show look kind of like you did
this to yourself what are you doing to
me
[Music]
game over i was told i cannot wait
[Music]
yikes
oh that's one hell of a distraction yeah
seriously i need to talk to you
i was stationed on mapuzo when the hunt
began the network runs out of the
certain sector i found evidence before
the escape impressive
unless of course
you're lying
stand where you are
[Music]
that you wish i was gonna have built-in
sunglasses now what does not make sense
is how an old man
and a little girl escaped an imperial
checkpoint
on your planet hmm admit you're a spy
of course i am when kenobi came they
panicked and
i got inside you expect me to believe
this i couldn't tell anybody
if they found out i would have been
killed
he's on floor
please don't get caught obi i want her
to live
[Music]
take her to interrogation ugh
if the debriefing confirms it
it's him
first time that gun's ever hit a target
[Music]
there you go hell yeah
[Music]
[Music]
slowly getting your groove back man i
wanted to be at peaked level so yeah
you could take down like so many
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
that's a good trick
[Music]
wait for it
wait
oh dick move
[Music]
you know he's keeping you guys alive
right now
[Music]
oh wow
put this on
what a great shot that's a great shot
[Laughter]
will suffer for this
[Music]
there's gonna be so much inquisiting
happening
stop
how are you gonna stick it to the
r-rated movie if you keep doing that
it's so close
[Music]
just keep going no
betraying everything you want oh god
that's never who i was and then you die
for nothing
you can take him come on do some [ __ ]
obiew
oh great
[Music]
got you sully just go destroy them
[Music]
the subtle use of the vader breath and
all these sound mixes
oh my god
i put a tracker on the ship
[Music]
where he goes
it will follow
oh okay
oh that's really sweet take her to live
with luke
[Music]
oh no of course yeah
it's evil no
evil reaver
did you like it more than the rise of
skywalker
[Laughter]
oh short man it was quick
right it's a smooth half hour yeah yeah
i felt really quick
is that a problem
oh no i don't think so
john
i mean i could think of a couple moments
i might have put a little more time into
suspense building for but overall i
don't think it hurts the episode too
much
guys
you know what gets the clicks is the
outrage i mean riva was in this episode
again oh
can't handle it the outrage
guys letting me town
so henry christensen was in the
back the tank i'm assuming yeah
and i think they use aspects of his
voice for vader
and then maybe match some of the voice
matching software that is doing james
earl jones's voice to that
[Music]
oh fascinating
this is a theory but
kind of like when they had a different
actor for vader in the first star wars
movie
and then they said
nah
let's use james earl jones forget this
doughy white guy
well i think they're using the
someone pointed out they're using the
reese feature technology yeah yeah the
same stuff that they did luke with so
yes i almost wonder if they have hayden
christensen do the lines and for the
cadence and for that that's a good point
and then they go back and they put james
earl jones with references from all of
his performances over top of that or
something yeah ah fascinating because
like la la not so much this episode but
uh one of the previous ones there were
moments where i was like i feel like
they're almost fading the two voices
together right right moments or
something but it's true
all right
well hey let's uh
let's talk about it let's talk about it
let's taco about it
everyone loved this episode
all right cool in the gang
we are here to talk about this episode
now you know the drill
um
yeah you know
i got i got some uh
you got to take these shows especially
this one the way that these episodes
start and stop
feel so much like i kind of wish this
was a bin show
because of the way the rhythm of how
these episodes start and stop because it
seems like you're supposed to take it in
as one whole package and not as an
episode by episode case especially when
it's one of those shows where the same
director of each one of every single
episode
so because i do have some
i do have some things i it's a lot i
really like about this show some things
i really do love and then there's other
parts where i'm like i guess i'll wait
to see the final episode before i
lay down the law of opinions up in here
because my opinion holds the most
highest of authorities
but we'll focus on the episode in and of
itself
i'm just here to tease my outrage
wokeness
right man yeah ace ace wokeness right
no
not at all woke army
goddamn obi-wan going through a fortress
wokeness ob woke they fighting
stormtroopers
no obi-wan troopers are white i'm just
saying
i'll be one a little weak
that must mean it's it's
woke
because because reba's strong anyway we
will we'll stop acknowledging them for
now
um
who went for john you go first this time
what did you think about this episode
tell the world why you thought it was
perfect on every account oh just nothing
could be better about this episode i
thought this was a decent episode and i
absolutely agree with what you just said
about it feeling as though it's part
the other previous episodes up until
this point have felt a bit more
well-rounded this is the shortest of
them so far and i feel like they
i feel like i we say this about disney
plus shows so often is i feel like they
could have taken a little bit of that
extra time that we're accustomed to and
maybe added it back in to flesh out some
of the real peril especially as it
pertains to obi-wan
getting the job done that was the thing
where i was like oh he he did it
can i interrupt really quick i have a
theory as to why this episode was so
short and why some things felt like they
were cut down abruptly does anyone want
to guess what my theory is because i
feel like we can guess it in this room
uh i mean
they as a jedi sympathizer they want
people to also watch miss marvel tonight
uh sure yeah i think if they wanted
people to watch miss marvel they
wouldn't put it in the same way you
think
yeah i think that's an easier way to do
that instead of making obi-wan shorter
you think well but we also live in a
world where most people can just watch
one and then the other at midnight if
they really care and they're not gonna
be in a studio shoot it's a conspiracy
theory ace
i don't know about that
i feel like it's so easy to put
why can't they just put miss marvel
thursday nights
because man thursday is a different day
it is it takes a lot you have to have
competency takes a lot of resources and
infrastructure to upload a video file
and then set it to public if we don't
compete with ourselves someone else is
going to compete with us
the boys have fridays so i don't know
they're like if they binge stranger
things then yeah they're going to bench
miss marvel and obi wan all right john
sorry to interrupt i just had uh my
conspiracy theory that he agreed with
all i could think of in this episode was
miss marvel
yeah uh i mean it was really cool to see
just the whole breadth of uh uh uh ace i
will consult your knowledge it's the uh
imperator
[Music]
the the inquisitors fortress stately
inquisitor manager is inquisitorius the
fortress inquisitorius there we go it
was very cool
it was very cool to be inside there and
to be on a sneaking mission and you know
to have these close calls this i really
think my favorite part of this episode
was the back and forth between riva and
leia i thought that was really good and
everything else was like cool in a video
game-esque kind of way um but it just
mainly left me wanting in the sense that
like i want to really feel the tension i
don't want to be distracted by my number
one pet peeve in shows and movies where
people are like talking
next to people who are going to hear and
discover them but for some reason their
voices don't carry
i don't know there were just little
things that that hampered the suspense
for me it was like a really cool
well-produced episode but uh yeah
i have some thoughts on the tension and
suspense of why i think overall in the
show it's sort of been lacking
but again
only teasing
the outrage
real outrage real religious
disney disney why do you disney
ace what are your thoughts on this
episode my friend i enjoyed it man um
it's definitely
an isolated
shorter
episode i definitely agree with what
you're saying though it definitely felt
like
i could kind of just keep watching the
next one it felt more like a in between
episode
uh kind of bridging probably the first
half in the second half of the season um
and i felt like this was kind of just
like the rescue leia we know she's gonna
get rescued but this is how it happens
let's do a quick 30 minute episode on
how it happens
um
so
i i did feel like it's definitely kind
of like that bridge in between
one that you can kind of quickly go
through if you were in the binge model
doing that so
yeah but i i definitely like what what
you were saying john as far as
the set design is so cool
it's so freaking cool like seeing her
being underwater seeing obi-wan swim
underwater
the the lighting was really cool like
all that stuff just works really
freaking well
and i feel like that's a big plus seeing
obi-wan take down stormtroopers cool
disney plus yeah disney plus
see nobody won't take down surf troopers
was cool to me um that's something we
haven't seen in a minute when their
torture chair was legitimately kind of
horrifying yeah i mean
that was the scariest part of the
episode it was a little jarring to see a
little girl scream uh in a torture
chamber uh that is definitely uh that
was a lot i mean it so that probe droid
in a new hope that was nothing
i mean there's there's various
interrogation droids uh throughout star
wars and yeah i'm just saying like
leia's come face to face
the ito interrogator
yeah
i think
the biggest issue i have with this show
so far
um
is because like i i agree with what you
guys are saying is cool it all is cool
and it's a big very cool very cool
uh that's a red arena wow wow
um
the oh you were doing pitch meeting i
was doing red letter b
movies so
like uh yeah cause i like going through
the inquisitor fortress is awesome i i
especially after you know playing jedi
fall in order like that it's felt so
much like the game look at it it's
working on the feelings i have from the
game
you know it was really it was it was
nice to see that
and i did like riva scenes a lot in here
uh the actors who play you know you
gotta
it's child actors it's uh i find it
really
um
mean if you rip into a child actor
and i know some people who have done it
when it comes to the late actors and i
don't think she's bad i i don't think
she's bad there are some times where
like eh yeah you know maybe you're a
child actor like wait what am i gonna
tell you
this is much
i expect less of you to be like so real
in a certain scene but there are times
where she does feel very real you know
sometimes when she sounds like
authoritative is when i have a hard time
believing her uh specifically but for
the most part i think she does a great
job and i'm not just saying that to be
nice i think she does a really good job
and i do think that back and forth to
them was nice it was kind of like a
different fliparoo from grand moff
tarkin and um grogu uh where
you know like
her bad not sith but sort of sith
interrogating important child you know i
mean uh uh kidding off gideon
who did i say grand moff tarkin oh my
bad
people are cushing back again from the
grave literally when you were saying
that i was like
i was like good pull but wait i don't
remember that no yeah should i fall in
order
yeah guys
i'm sorry they kind of sound a little
bit similar in some way now i'm going to
get crap for saying that
the letters are so different gray
um
i was i was thinking of mandalorian
season two um yeah it was kind of making
me think of that we're not really sith
but you know can do
sort of sith stuff whatever you don't
get um
uh yeah i like that i think the biggest
issue i have with this show right now is
it is
this this i i like
because it's like i'm kind of back and
forth i was so i find that so warm with
the whole scene with like leia holding
obi-wan's hand and you know obi-wan
feeling
kind of directionless in his life like
i've just been here on tattooing
watching this boy and i i don't know if
i'm contributing to this at all and now
to see this effect he's had on layla and
showing how necessary
he was to be there for and and the bond
is is such a great part of this episode
at times though the focus of this show
of it being obi-wan and leia
and then trying to emit all this
suspense and danger
i i have a hard time
buying into it because it's such a
central focus of the show and i don't
feel the fear of it because i'm like
well
obviously leia's gonna be fine it is
such an obvious thing
whereas i'll feel the the concern and
worry for
character whose name i'm not currently
remembering who is the taller riva
riva i'm so worried reba's gonna die
no tala yeah i'll feel concerned for
tala in those scenes you know and that's
why like mandalorian works so well
because these are new characters we
don't know they're the the path they're
on and there's and so i like it here's
how i would describe it
i feel like i would actually appreciate
a lot of the story more if i picked up a
book and i read it and like oh it's kind
of cool to learn the backstory of this
but in terms of a suspenseful show
especially a show that's really trying
to be so suspenseful and so intense and
not really do much character exploration
in between to ju like like a lot of
intimate character moment scenes
it lacks a lived-in quality yes so i'm
that's a big part of what's missing for
me here is like i like the account
concept and i like the idea and there
are parts about it i really do enjoy
um but when it comes to building like
actual tension out of it i'm like nah i
don't really i don't really feel it and
uh especially for an episode like this
it's supposed to be like
pulse pounding but thrusting you right
into the action and i'm like yeah
i'm kind of just watching it though
i mean i feel like the tension
feel like the tension that we're trying
to build up was more about
the safety of leia if that makes sense
more than necessarily
her
dying or being captured forever like i i
think that the scene where she's about
to get tortured
you i i did feel the tension because i
definitely felt like oh crap this is
leia
you know that's weird i didn't feel it
at all really i was like nothing's gonna
happen
i'm in between you i'm like this is the
most tense i feel during this episode
but it is a short-lived moment and i
feel like they maybe were afraid to go
too heavily into child and peril torture
device sequence it's so obvious
something was going to happen
yeah well i mean i i i don't know i kind
of felt like they could probably go
there because
they
hinted at going there in a new hope uh
and obviously they've hinted at going
there in a various other media when
different people are being tortured uh
so i did feel that tension i also feel
like a lot of it too has to do with more
of the
prequel
ideology if that makes sense where it's
more about
not necessarily like oh well we know
anakin's not gonna die in this episode
we all know that and we all know that
obi-wan is going to be fine in all those
other movies but we still feel some sort
of tension that's why solo worked for me
as well solo star wars story um
there was moments where you were like oh
this is crazy but we know they're going
to survive you still felt it because of
the characters that were involved in
because the way it was shot produced
edited all that kind of stuff so i i i
think it works i think it works for what
they're trying to tell i just feel like
this episode itself
was so
quick and to the point and short
that there might not be enough to chew
on necessarily fair enough i mean like i
i don't i don't agree with these because
there are some people who just write off
the concept of a prequel in in totality
of it of of what i just of the stuff i
was expressing
it's like there's the difference between
something like x-men origins wolverine
and something like x-men first class to
me like x-men first class i think is so
effective in one of the best x-men
movies and that's such a prequel and you
know it's going to head down a path
where like charles and eric are probably
not going to be friends with it you know
and uh revenge of the sith i think is a
great film i love that movie
um but there's there's something about
the the intimate details that feels i i
that's the hard part about explaining i
i i have a hard time with different how
to how to explain it because i guess it
just comes down to a subjective feeling
on the matter you know
i can't convince you to feel a certain
way and you can't but but i feel like a
lot of that has to do with the season
versus the episode right
where this season might give you what
you're asking for but this episode
specifically maybe didn't give you that
but maybe that's not necessarily what
the episode was going for i've never
really felt it for
any of the episodes with leia of like oh
no
you're in danger
well i think i i think
the troubling the tricky thing about
prequels is often that you're both
further along in times you have better
technology and you have the foregone
conclusions and i think the way that you
it's going to come right back to this is
the way that you temper that is to
really invest us in the personal stakes
the characters in the moment so that it
doesn't matter if you know the outcome
because you know how hard these trials
are going to be
and
again it's that lived in quality it's
like they've given it to us in little
fits and bursts and i think all the
actors are killing it for the most part
i think there are you can tell the
homework is there uh and i would love i
feel like this show more than any other
show perhaps in the star wars universe
uh pitched thus far
like we did so much of like boba fett of
just like looking at his past and he's
with the tuscans and it's very sort of
uh poetically shot and it's not really
dialogue heavy and i'm like you could do
stuff like that here with obi-wan and
really get into his
psyche because this is your opportunity
to do better what they did or at least
more agreeably for everybody what they
tried to do with luke skywalker in the
last jedi you know it's like this is a
different version of obi-wan than the
pinnacles that we know him from let's
dive into that state of being and it's
there in his performance but i don't
feel like it's much there in the writing
it's very action-oriented it's very
straightforward action-oriented these
past couple episodes have been i've been
like that quite a bit
um
ace why are we wrong
i mean i i think
i think the focus i i feel like a lot of
people might be
maybe it is because she's a little girl
and because it's land because it's such
an iconic character but the
the focus is still on obi-wan and i
still feel like sure
everything we got from obi-wan in every
single episode so far has been killer
like has been really freaking good
whether it is the acting whether it is
the backstory whether it is even the
action kind of the build up to him
getting in shape uh but i think that's
kind of a cool little way of like
slowly but surely building his way up to
fighting shape i think that's something
we haven't really seen in star wars
before and it's something that is really
clever the way they build it into the
show it's not necessarily
you know is obi-wan going to get out of
the situation it's how is he going to
get out of the situation it's how he's
going to overcome the stormtroopers it's
how many stormtroopers he's going to
take out is he going to use the force to
take them out is he going to use this to
take him out like i think that's a
clever way to get us invested into the
action is to show us his build up into
the force and using the four thousand
percent as a way to fight off these
storm troopers is he gonna go ham and
just take down like 40 like all that
kind of stuff to me is a really cool way
for deborah chow to kind of showcase
where obi-wan is at in this journey yeah
i like the last half of this episode a
lot the last half is what really got me
very i was that's when i was feeling it
especially when he did start using his
lightsaber and started using the force
because i do like the story concept of
you know it's it's it's kind of a
typical action story just about the star
wars backdrop of you know uh traumatized
action hero is retired and then he's
pulled back out of retirement to save
little girl it's it's a very got a big
beard it's logan it's a billion other
action
it's a bunch of action movies and now
we're doing it with the jedi way and
you're watching him slowly get it back
in tune with the force
and uh
i so i i really like that whole scene
you know especially when he is holding
the water and you get to see leia really
witness him being like this guy really
cares about me
he's really protecting me right now he's
a he's a real jedi you know and it's
giving her something to believe in too
in terms of this rise of the rebellion
um and whatnot
uh i i really i really appreciate those
nuances and those details and i guess i
find myself more often
craving um the the way i'm receptive to
that i find myself craving more of that
feeling more with this show
um and and i think that's kind of what
starts to lack for me and i had a
question about vader
what's his deal in this exactly because
there was a lot of people who were
bitching about it and i was like ah i'm
sure there's he's got a motive for it a
lot of people bitched about how he could
have he like wanted obi-wan to suffer
or something with the fire right and
then
and then they watched him get away and
he didn't like put the fire out or try
to get vape or try to get obi-wan back
in the last episode and it seemed like
he was around here at the fortress then
after all the [ __ ] goes down he just
comes storming and like everyone good
god why you know and and so i i don't
quite
i feel like they'll eventually fully
reveal it to us but i'm not quite
getting what they're doing with with
vader yeah i mean i think they i think
they said that he was in mustafar and he
wasn't on or he wasn't in the fortress
that he was on in his castles
so he wasn't there and i feel like
that's like a trope too with vader is
that he's never
really there no like i really think
that's an actual trope yeah whether it's
empire strikes back yeah you're right
about that um i think that's something
that's a really so you're the expert to
remember details that we just learned 20
minutes ago it's a way to feature other
characters especially the inquisitors
and and reva and
and to not rely too heavily on vader
just being like
monologuing monologue and monologuing
like to make it more about obi-wan's
journey and to make vader kind of the
final threat or the final boss at the
end versus just having him show up
everywhere and chase him down and stuff
i i think that's to me that's a better
way of showcasing vader is in small bits
and pieces rather than him just kind of
running after obi-wan i think though
that the way how disney marketed this
show
is working against it in a lot of ways
you think they've marketed vader a lot
because
that was like the big hype about this
i don't i don't
i don't know he was i mean he was in the
trailer but he wasn't like no not i mean
yeah and
uh i feel like the inquisitors were
trying more than twitter once definitely
but when this show was announced sure
you know like you're way more of an
extreme star wars fan than john and i
yeah but we know we stay plugged in
though to what people are talking about
and even the first sizzle reel for this
the the like the first actual look at
this [ __ ] you know and then like the
promotions are all like hayden
christensen and then darth vader and
then the sizzle reel was like they're
gonna battle it out again and and
justice for hayden christensen there's
so much about that and i think that it i
think they did create an expectation in
one's mind because nothing is more
intriguing
i don't think anything with riva
or
any of the inquisitors is more
intriguing than exploring more of that
and that the depths of that like the
third episode is like the best for many
people for a reason
and
and and i think that we like i like all
this other stuff i mean the inquisitors
or whatever to me i like all this other
stuff for the most part
but
i i do get a little bit like
i wonder if like the last episode's just
gonna be so
anakin obi-wan heavy you know i imagine
that's where they're going and and i
don't want to be the guy who's like
bitching about something when i know
that's probably gonna happen later on
it's just will we get there smoothly and
and i don't know if you how you felt
about book of boba fett i really didn't
like the final episode i was really let
down by it
um
and i don't want it to be another disney
plus mess where
oh it's going good it's going great ah
but man they dropped the ball in the
finale i i definitely feel you on that
especially with marvel shows for me
where marvel shows tonight and we're
talking about star wars
true but
you said just keep marvelous
out of the mouth i said dizzy plus did i
say marvel huh huh i'm so sorry kevin
i'm sorry i'm sorry if you're watching
this mr feige please don't he will not
be on
it's anymore a reason or your star wars
movie any marvel shows
uh no but i do feel like i know what you
mean as far as like
the finale being a little bit too much
versus trying to focus on the like we're
gonna wrap this [ __ ] up
on the story yeah to me
i i don't know because i i don't really
when it comes to marketing it's
difficult because you do want to have
when you have an actor like hayden
christensen come back for a role
whether it be a small part in the role
whether it be a huge part in the role i
think you have to feature him in
marketing as far as in press and stuff
like that because it's a way to
give credence to an actor that has been
a part of star wars for such a long time
to be completely honest i think me and a
few other people out there i think
as far as star wars youtube channel star
wars explained for example
didn't have those high expectations when
it came to hating christensen because we
kind of were like okay they're featuring
him a lot in marketing it doesn't
necessarily mean we're gonna get
flashbacks of hayden we're gonna get
vader or a bunch of times out of the
suit like we kind of expected
very little because we know that at this
point in his life
anakin is vader
so the very few times we will see hayden
is going to be few and far between so i
feel like that was more of just like a
shout out a credence a
appreciation for hayden
more than it was like oh he's going to
be in every episode and he's going to be
featured and we're going to get a back
story we're going to get flashback like
i didn't feel that
when it came to the marketing i just
felt like this is hayden christensen
he's worthy of being recognized as
anakin and vader i just keep wondering
what the emotional direction of the show
is going for with obi-wan too
you're like how is this guy gonna arc
into
the obi-wan who's like alright so i'm
going back to tattooing
i'm just going to hang out here for a
while now
yeah i mean i i think we'll figure that
out though i still feel like we have
time um
it's an hour and a half of this left ace
come on maybe an hour and 45 minutes if
episode if the last one's long we talked
about the outrage it's difficult for me
to pre-judge
something when it's not finished no
that's why i love you because it's way
too reasonable
that's very no that's very true man
that's very true it's very true like yo
rescued ladies so i'm underwater this
show sucks like for me it's like i'm not
saying that let's uh other people
i don't know but i'm saying like i think
i think we still have a story to tell i
feel like a story isn't just
uh you know one journey a story is a
you know sections and factions of sure
little adventures how do we get to where
we are uh what happens as far as
along the journey to get there true and
i'm just saying i guess for me
i don't know how you feel it's like the
the journey for me has been a little
emotional emotionally hit and miss for
me
to like
cool information to oh i'm actually
really invested in this and and every
episode is kind of episode three i was
invested really invested it for the most
part but the other the other ones i've
i'm kind of like really weaving in and
out
of i'm just kind of gathering
information versus i'm really feeling
this moment that's why i would not write
this show off
um
no i i think i mean i think especially
with this show there's something fair to
be said for the idea that it is being
billed heavily as a limited series so in
that sense i'm like yes benefit of the
doubt let's see how the whole thing
looks at the end however i would say we
are now four episodes in out of six and
i feel like for my experience there
to be satisfied at this point i feel
like there's gonna be a lot of emotional
leg work to do in the last two episodes
because the show has felt very again
straightforward and plot oriented and
and looking at even the core
you know sort of relationship and
distance between
uh obi-wan and anakin vader you know
even that like vader shows up and is
really scary for moments uh but i feel
like you know most of what i know about
what that story's development is thus
far as
vader's pretty upset and traumatized
over the last time he saw obi-wan so he
kind of wants to get him and probably
hurt him i guess the emotional meat is
there it's just not taking center stage
for me um yeah i mean i i think to be
honest it's it's a lot to do with this
episode i feel like this episode was
very much like you think it's all about
this one episode no i'm saying it i'm
saying the the i mean
the meat of this episode was so thin
that it's just a little bit difficult to
to kind of like feel it in this episode
and i agree with you guys when it comes
to like really having something to chew
on and the emotional stakes in this
episode because there wasn't a lot there
unless you were like you said john a fan
of that uh leia and reva interaction but
other than that that was kind of it the
rest of the episode was much more of
like how do we go from point a to point
b
which
is probably a detriment to the episode
but again like you said john i feel like
when it comes to the complete package of
it
i i don't know i think a lot of it too
has to do with
perhaps the way we view different shows
nowadays sure i just binge stranger
things i think if i saw like
episode three or episode two by itself i
probably wouldn't be that
invested if i'm being honest uh but
seeing like three or four episodes in a
row it made me feel a little bit more
hooked and made me feel a little bit
more connected to where the story was
going and even then it still very much
felt like half a story which again it is
it's part one but i feel like that's
just the way
we're viewing different episodes and
shows now it's like we're taking bits
and pieces of a story versus the entire
story the way you feel about stranger
things is how i feel about this yeah
yeah gotcha i'd agree with that because
i feel like i don't know man i still
feel like if i'm being real uh i think i
got more
in these three episodes than i did
probably in the first three of stranger
things
i think golly i think
ace isn't coming back forever it's it's
been nice to know you
megna is out to get him
see those are going to the upside there
that show i was like put that thing week
to week and this one i'm wondering maybe
this would like you said earlier maybe
this would make it better be interesting
yeah i i didn't feel that way especially
with an episode like this uh it makes me
really feel like this might have been
better if i watched this episode might
have been better if i just watched it
immediately after
but even then it's like this i don't
know there's something about it this one
was it also did feel really rushed it's
like you meet o'shea jackson who's like
no i'm not helping you five seconds
later all right i talked myself into
about remembering why i'm doing this in
the first place
you know that was just for me guys
like i i and then these people die at
the end
and to be honest or that guy that the
weight guy dies at the end
and
i don't i don't give a [ __ ] like i'm
like honestly dude i don't even remember
you from five minutes ago like i don't
remember who you are and we walk around
inside of a jedi tomb trophy room you
know which is that's right and i think i
think
i don't want to say the word milk it ah
live in it live in it yeah like live in
it or do some like hollywood
romanticizing or some [ __ ]
terminology of
of like let's like like obi-wan fighting
the stormtroopers and using his powers
actually watching him get his powers
back like really make a
strong emotional moment out of that
you know more like
oh
that might just be the like the way it's
edited or the way it breathes sometimes
of like that scene when when leia holds
his hand that took its time and that hit
and they could have done that with so
many more moments in this one episode
that if you're not gonna do like a bunch
of dialogue exchanges to uncover
character background at least really let
those moments hit i agree i i feel like
oh my god
something
welcome to the time i've been sweating i
disagree i've changed my mind
yeah we're so close
so much better this year
at
every criticism you have is valid but i
don't feel like that's necessarily a
criticism of the show more than it is a
criticism of this episode this episode
did feel
like it was rushed it did feel like it
didn't have as much meat to it it did
feel like it didn't have as much
emotional stakes to it but i feel like
that's more a detriment to
a standalone episode more than it is a
detriment to the entire shows in general
amen um i hope you are correct yeah
well guys
do you prefer this for stranger things
[Laughter]
i prefer this
wow really how about the boys
anybody no i i don't see the boys i
don't watch the boys wow
thanks for not helping that go watch
this morning reaction
right now
disney plus everything's out
all right guys yeah
well leave your thoughts down below
um that's good good open discussion this
was a nice discussion guys i did it i'm
a tad harsher
ace is a lot more
happy
you're like kind of in between that's
right i'm the gray jedi either we don't
talk about it
it's not canon i guess but maybe i'm the
jedi who's like [ __ ] jedi i can't
muslim i swear to push me in the goddamn
dark side
of that
jedi skywalker
can be repressed a bit
follow jedi do you think we'll see
quinlan vos
i mean
that kind of looked like quinlan boss in
that
and officially he is and okay
i'm sorry to say this if it is quinlan
boss
and they didn't make a moment out of it
this show's [ __ ]
this and that's not just because oh my
god we're using clone wars and you're
ruining no they had a whole moment in
the last episode when he's like yeah
quinlan was here
but i'm not going to spend any time with
his course yeah i'm not going to even
acknowledge but even yeah like but that
scene too would have just really hit of
just that could have been a big
most triggering moment for him should
have been that moment yeah you know i
mean seeing that youngling was was was
it was quick but it was still like oh we
should have lingered on this a tiny bit
more yeah so yeah wow how'd they embalm
them like that who whose idea was it to
be like you put the hat back on that
young lady they saw jurassic park and
they were like let's let's get us some
amber and let's freeze some moments in
time do you like his outfit i think we
should change it like no probably though
like that's how just that's how sick
they are they probably do like like a
museum they primp them yeah yeah
we gotta get one of those yeah we need a
tomb hallway promise me when i dies
i have one of those in your home yeah
me
but but make sure that's like we're
gonna pose you the right way yeah i want
to be one of the hard-to-reach corpses
on the second level that you can't
really sit and admire it reminded me of
uh of the scene in young justice where
they have him in stasis
uh i think it's desperate where they or
[ __ ] it might be [ __ ] where they keep
him don't mess this up man
um
it's very similar like if i show you
guys an image you guys will be like oh
they could have taken it from that
because it looks very similar well dude
star wars is all about easter eggs and
references now
that's all matters as long as you do
that you're
in there you're gonna start referencing
other ips now star wars gonna get really
have you seen young justice
somehow the longest video of ours is the
shortest episode of star wars we had to
make up for last time
like what the hell did we just
think we just inserted the whole episode
here
all right
all right guys this video is truly done
but before that let's do a page
andrew hayes so andrew hey something
about andrew hayes you probably get
along with this guy pretty well
uh he's been like one of our patrons for
the longest time years man years
uh short stocky fella cat talks like
this and uh he's he and he's a freaking
he's like adorable but intimidate the
same time you know he's like wolverine
yeah yeah yeah he's great um
and uh he was telling me a story
recently about how he was at a bachelor
party this is true i don't know if you
know if you want some reveal
i might have
this is where i've severed the cord
no longer a picture of my favorite told
you this is
uh he was at a bachelor party and and
then they got kicked out of uh i believe
it was a strip club before they thought
they they were soliciting prostitution
there
and uh legalize it and i i i would
believe i mean and to be frank andrew if
i saw you and i heard that i would be
like yeah probably i mean look at the
guy right this guy who loves
prostitution he looks like the kind of
guy he would right just get you a
leather jacket
he'll still stick around you could be a
crooked
how do you survive andrew and then uh
and then a friend of theirs um they went
home on a on a scooter like an electric
scooter and they lost the scooter and
their phone on the way home and they
didn't know how they didn't know how to
get home for a while
so and then the prostitutes all showed
up and helped yes
gave them a lift they all pushed a
scooter they all ironically leaned out
the window themselves and said hey do
you need a ride
sexual services
we're also a towing where'd you play
yeah if you subscribe we'll get you out
of a jam it's all right we get a new
battery get new tires andrew you don't
need to go down that path but if you do
there's nothing wrong with it but you
don't need to do it you can get a woman
all on your own i believe in you andrew
i mean if it's wolverine then
yeah
he cut some women up if you slash that
seems better than love
yeah and if they stick around with you
then you know you got real love
ain't that right ace that's right real
love baby are you sick bastard i was
making a joke wow don't you have a a
woman on your channel
a squad leader respect women how would
you how would you feel if she heard you
say yes and to that
well
sabrina would you come in here please we
got sabrina oh we have sabrina here we
had a big surprise
caught in the act
we're here to get you canceled today
i'm just hitting cameras everywhere
ashton kutcher come on out ashton
kutcher he's still alive
he's yeah yeah yeah he invests in in big
tech now like andrew could someday after
he gets out of his jail shot
prostitution this is the longest
non-shout out we've ever done thanks
andrew
you